you're in vandersloite the suspect in
The Disappearance of Natalie Holloway
was in an Alabama courtroom on Friday
Holloway vanished in 2005 while in a
high school graduation trip with
classmates in Aruba her body has never
been found she was last seen alive with
your and vandersloe Holloway's family is
hoping a federal case against him will
finally lead to answers Michael George
is here with more on this Michael good
morning Jeff good morning 18 years
that's how long this case has gone
unsolved well now the prime suspect in
Holloway's disappearance was flown from
Peru to Alabama to face charges but not
for murder he's charged with extorting
Holloway's family
35 year old jorin vandersloed a Dutch
national now in the custody of
Birmingham Alabama authorities refused a
translator when he pled not guilty to
charges of extortion
he was the last person to see Natalie
Holloway alive before she disappeared on
the island of Aruba during a 2005 High
School graduation trip the case
attracted International attention
vandersloot was twice arrested but never
charged in Holloway's disappearance he's
long maintained his innocence then in
2010 a Federal grand jury indicted him
accusing vandersload of trying to extort
250 thousand dollars from Holloway's
mother Beth in exchange for details
about the location of Natalie's body the
information was false Holloway was
declared legally dead in 2012 and while
there's still no evidence of what
happened to her the extortion charges
against Vander Slaughter seen as an
important step for forward according to
Mark White the family's attorney
it can be accountability and perhaps
maybe opportunity for the truth to
finally to come out Beth Holloway
Natalie's mother who was in court Friday
is quoted as saying it's been a very
long and painful Journey but we're
finally getting Justice for Natalie she
spent 18 years pushing investigators to
find out what happened to her daughter
now even if vandersloat is convicted he
won't see jail time in the U.S anytime
soon that's because he'll be spending
the next 15 years in a Peruvian prison
after pleading guilty to the murder of
another woman 21 year old Stephanie
Flores Dana never underestimate what a
mother will do to keep something going
for her child Michael thank you